nous avons pensé
que la situation était très grave
et qu'il n'était pas prise au sérieux et
que alors quand même il y avait ainsi
très grave qui était la sphère paty et
qu' on en tirait pas les leçons que nous
dénonçons aussi c'est l'attitude de la
toile du chef d'établissement qui a osé
critiqué l'octroi de la protection
fonctionnelle en disant que pour el
salam sall a choqué et qu'elle appuie la
position qu'ils n'aient pas accès je
dénoncerai l'attitude de
l'administration pas clairement et nous
demandons que la des sanctions
la collègue a été dans un premier temps
elle était en arrêt maladie
ensuite on a rencontré l'avocat on a
créé le point d'étape est revenue
plusieurs fois y compris en vision parce
que c'est compliqué la commune pour que
la collègue rejoignent plus
l'établissement à la rentrée de lille à
terre parce qu'elle a passé l'année
scolaire ailleurs la collègue insu nous
ne mendions que les choses soient faites
et alain arrêté qui la nomme sur
laquelle amy ou là elle est près de sa
famille et sécuriser
notre action c'est de défendre les
collègues qui sont systématiquement
maintenant on peut placer en placer en
position d'accusé et de réclamer de
l'administration elles défendent les
collèges et qu'elle organise ces
rencontres justement très pratique très
causant près faisable dans lesquelles on
peut voir
les problèmes clairement et échanger
discuter